bienvenue à paroles autochtones ici
c'est mélissa mollen dupuis cette
semaine encore une fois fait distance
est loin de vous même par exemple si ce
qui m'a le plus inspiré cette semaine
c'est en fait une distance physique mais
on n'a pas besoin de faire une distance
sociale etc le hashtag sochaux dustin
brown qui m'a vraiment ramener de la
bonne humeur dans ma semaine on peut
parler de paroisse à distance ou de télé
paoua c'est une chance qui est venu sur
les médias sociaux que ce soit secteur
que ce soit instagram ou facebook où les
gens ont commencé à se transformer de
leurs vêtements du quotidien alors
regalia de pas voir on a pu voir des
femmes des hommes des enfants se
transforment et de ses vêtements de tous
les jours vers des vêtements qui sont
très flamboyant qui représente leur
nation leur fierté culturelle
on en a vues d'amérique du nord mais on
oublie aussi de la nouvelle zélande et
ça je pense que c'est venu en réaction
fait que tous les paroles se sont
annulés un peu partout à travers le
monde
ce sont des moments d'échangé culturel
très important on était souvent sur le
territoire pendant l'automne l'hiver et
le printemps et l'été servait à ces
échanges à préparer les mariages à a
créé à faire des échanges d'avoir des
relations en font les uns avec les
autres
malheureusement les parents autant nul
et on est obligé de garder une distance
physique mais pour garder cette ce
rapprochement social que donnent les
parents ils ont décidé de montrer leur
fierté quand même sur les médias sociaux
dont vous pouvez voir les gens danser
chanter représenter la fierté culturelle
avec l'aide de leur téléphone
il ya une version extrêmement pour moi
qui étais me réchauffer le coeur
énormément c'était quand malheureusement
on a dû annuler in una comme où c'était
la 36ème édition cette année
plusieurs chanteurs de la côte-nord les
innu et des attikameks aussi ont décidé
de se réunir et de faire une reprise de
la version
je dirais social distance pas avoir de
moindre poids qui est une chanson je
dirais l'hymne je désigne une des
premières chansons enregistrées en
hainaut emon tout le monde la connaît et
on part en makusham à chaque fois qu'on
l'entend et bien en la reprenant ils en
ont fait un vidéo est devenue virale sur
youtube 10000 view de cette chanson-là
et de montrer sa fierté de montrer sa
culture et de dire que c'est pas parce
que on peut pas cette année qu'on pourra
pas l'année prochaine
et voici ce qu'en disait bon ben tant
pis ce sera la prochaine fois on va
quand même continuer c'était quand même
un hymne à la résilience des premières
nations des premiers peuples donc le
champ justement se transformer cette
cette culture de dire qu'on va continuer
d'être ensemble
malgré tout et je pense qu'avec
l'histoire qu'on a eu on a prouvé que
nos champs et nos danses vont continuer
encore et encore et que ce ne sera que
la prochaine fois donc allés visiter
justement ces vidéos la suivait les mots
clics ce jour de ce type à wau
surchauffe du stenting pas wells en
anglais mais on pourrait précédent créé
en français et d'ailleurs je pense
qu'ils ont une très belle série qui
vient de malioténam si je me trompe pas
avec des jeunes filles qui dansent en
jeans redresse
c'est merveilleux alors n'hésitez pas à
vous remplir les yeux et les oreilles de
cultures et de vous dire que ceci n'est
qu'un moment à passer
alors fait une belle semaine j'espère
que vous n'hésiterez pas à partager
cette vidéo et n'hésitez pas surtout à
nous envoyer des sujets qui pourraient
vous intéresser
en ces temps troublés bonne semaine